I know why you're excited it's
Presidents Day weekend and it's a good
time to reflect how far we've come from
our first president who said I cannot
tell a lot and you know I know it's fun
to watch the wheels come off the Trump
car until we remember we're riding in
the back that it's not so [ __ ] fun
anymore
and as usual you know there's the circus
that happens every week the distractions
that take us away from knowing what's
really important which is there is an
unprecedented state of crisis in this
country there is Secord to the National
Security Advisor Michael Flynn resigned
because it is illegal contact with
Russia I know the president would like
to say that's fake news that's not fake
news this is the most serious political
scandal we've ever had in the United
States and now the question turns to how
deep was the involvement of President
Trump or as Russia calls him Agent
Orange
what is going on in this country is the
intelligence agencies are leaking like
crazy because they are trying to send a
desperate message that this is not just
a different kind of president as the
Republican enablers like a different
kind of president Sisi no he's [ __ ]
nuts and he's dangerous and they know it
and they're trying to tell us that you
know what makes the intelligence
agencies go nuts
seems like this from Mara Largo this
last weekend when he was with the
Japanese Prime Minister and they got
news at dinner that the North Koreans
had launched a missile
so Trump thought he would you know just
handle it at dinner in an open-air
restaurant
he's with the Japanese Prime Minister
they probably handled intelligence
briefings like they do at their steak
houses right there at your table this is
crazy [ __ ] and yet foreign heads of
state keep coming to America as if it's
normal as if things are not Netanyahu
from Israel was here this weekend no
Trump doesn't know anything that's the
other little bad part about him they
asked him about the two-state solution
he said it works for me and Melania
and then justin trudeau where my
canadian dear I don't Erica debt they're
small but enthusiastic but he came and
sat down with the president you know and
he had that same look on his face that
all the leaders have like oh [ __ ] and
I'm sure it came up that they have
floated seriously in the White House
Sarah Palin as the first ambassador not
the first the last ambassador to Canada
which I'm sure Trudeau takes more as a
threat Sarah Palin ambassador the first
ambassador in history to require a
security deposit know that that's what
they do they love these distractions
what the crazy they were bailing over
here meanwhile they're doing this [ __ ]
like the Senate confirmed just today
Scott Pruett to be head of the
environmental head of the Environmental
Protection Agency Scott Pruett is a man
who despises
the Environmental Protection Agency so
it's less like public service and more
like community service this is a guy who
is completely in the tank for the
extraction industry that's how they roll
the new head of the APA is completely in
the tank with the oil and the cold
that's how Republicans work with Donald
Trump while you're watching the clown
screw the pony they're breaking into
your car
let's remember that now in other cabinet
news Andy Posner is out it sounds like
something somebody says to you when your
fly's open a andy puzzler is out now he
was the anti-labor guy they put up to be
labor secretary and and now they're
putting up a guy Alexander Acosta I have
no idea how this guy slipped through
because he's qualified and Hispanic so
it's going to be a very tough
confirmation process and an even tougher
Border Patrol
and then there was the press conference
did you see Donald Trump's press
conferences press conference and
impromptu 77 minute brains part is what
he's like I mean you know your Facebook
friend who said he thought Trump was
Hitler he was optimistic actually what
we have here is a mental patient who
thinks he's Hitler the kid in the
YouTube video whose high from the
dentist made more sense it was and of
course it was his log winey winey little
[ __ ] airing of grievances against the
press and the cords in the Democrats and
Hillary Justice non-stop pissing and
moaning and kissing and moaning there's
less pissing and moaning when he's with
his Russian hooker
I met in the middle of it he says the
White House is running like a fine-tuned
machine yes with subtly a samsung galaxy